[Music]
at what point did you know I'm sure I
know that you've talked about it a ton
but like I knew like two uh like I knew
the moment basically the moment that we
met like in so like when I I think I've
said this before but when I was
proposing I made this video for her
like kind of going through our whole
relationship and
because I was on the beach and ever our
families were all inside the house and I
was waiting on the beach and she went
inside the house they surprised her and
she was confused and they were like
watch this video and they all watched
the video together
and the end slide was me basically being
like you know but I've known the whole
time and then it was a screenshot of a
of a message that I sent to my to my
friend in Australia and I was like it
was like the the second time that we had
hung out so this is like three days
after we met or something like that and
I was like I met my wife oh my God and
and then and then it was like come down
to the beach
like I want to ask you a question that
was like the light the last thing on the
thing but so like that's just proof that
like I basically knew like right away
and for me it was like
it's just like it's just like the the
connection like I knew like right away
it's like oh we have something there's
something here we just totally
understand each other and maybe it is
like sense of humor just personalities
but like that is so huge for me like I
cannot hang out with a person that I
don't like
you know that that that doesn't exist
you know yeah and I just feel like I was
dating people that I just didn't
that wasn't there and I just it was like
hard to hang out with them you know
totally I just that was like over and
over and over again it was like oh man I
just like I'm looking forward to this
person leaving yeah you know did you
guys ever have any rough times any rough
patches yes it's just oh yeah yeah yeah
for sure like what that's very
surprising we had some
yeah there was some uh definitely we've
been through some rough patches for sure
yeah
um
you know I don't know like
some like deaths and stuff and and
obviously kovid right like that was like
we had moved into this like tiny
apartment together that was like our
first place and then all of a sudden
covet happened so we went from being on
tour like touring the world to like
locked in a small apartment with just
the two of you like that'll really test
the relationship sure that was generally
great but you know there's like other
things that happened and
um so it definitely wasn't all like
sunshine and happiness along the way for
sure but I think like after those things
happen it's like it's like you know it's
a reminder it's like we made it we made
it through that and it was like
didn't destroy us yeah you know I had uh
but it's never it's never all easy you
know no of course yeah it's it's um and
if it is I feel like that's worrisome
sure yeah yeah if it's too easy all the
time yeah you need some conflict you
gotta have some then you know how you
handle adversity yeah
man yeah one one thing that um breakup
Tick Tock is taught me because you know
it's sending me all the [__] it's that
uh
it it sounds like a um
I don't know a Trope or whatever but
it's like oh you know love is choosing
the person over and over and over you
have to make the conscious choice
through challenges and ups and downs you
are actively choosing the person and not
like throwing in the towel
or giving up because that's what you do
when you meet the right person you know
and uh
yeah that's a it's a tough one when
you're when you're dealing with [__]
like covet and yeah I'm looking back at
some things where I'm like oh holy
[__] [__] that was um
I still chose and maybe I [__]
shouldn't have because of yeah like whoa
um
chose what the person oh yeah yeah
but you know that's that's what you do
you
yeah covert was tough yeah I mean like
also covert was tough and then
afterwards I think it's like
you know the pandemic was how long like
two years depending on who you ask yeah
but like then after that it was like I
never really I think there's like a lot
of people still that like didn't that
haven't like digested like the damage
that it really did sure like to you know
like just our mental States like I think
there's like a lot of things that people
are still coping with they don't even
realize and for me it was like I was
like massively like last year I was like
massively depressed and like just like
also like drinking way too much too
because like in the pandemic like that's
what I would do
and like that lasted you know and that
like affects your just general emotional
state and I feel like
I feel like that was really hard on our
relationship too you drinking not me
drinking but like more it just like
not getting enough sleep being sad not
not have feeling like I have a purpose
yeah it's like hard to connect you know
it's like one person can only be so
supportive yeah you know not to say that
she wasn't but I'm just saying it's like
it's hard for me you have to like feel
like especially for a guy it feels like
it's like I have to like feel like I
have like a purpose yeah in order for me
to like truly like give myself to
I know it's hard to explain but I hear
you it just was like I just feel like
we weren't connecting for a little while
but again it's like you just gotta work
that [__] out I had someone
um
I was in a relationship with someone who
uh
because in with that with that woman who
was nine years older than me my big big
thing that she harped on many times was
that I didn't show up for her and I
didn't really I knew what that meant but
I also was like yeah what the [__] does
that what do you mean but now I know
um because I was in some I was in a
thing and uh I was with this person and
we were uh
we were at a Climbing Gym
and I was I was encouraging her to like
oh you know you got it you got the final
move like you got to find a move and she
was like I don't think I do I was like
you got it you got it and uh
she slipped and she fell and sprained
her ankle real bad and got really mad at
me like it was my fault okay and I was
like
I felt terrible I'm like I'm I'm sorry
like I I'm not up there you if you're
gonna if you don't think you can do it
drop down like you've done that before
where I'm going hey you got it you gotta
drop down and uh
she ended up having to wear a [__]
Boot and crutches for months and was
really mad at me and was like why did I
listen to you and why were you pushing
me and I was like I'm sorry and then uh
I was I I then was um so this is on the
being showing up and being a good
boyfriend being a good partner that I
wasn't before
I was like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go
to the store I'm gonna get you some
groceries and uh go to the store come
back and this person's kitchen was
always kind of in disarray and fridge
was full of uh expired [__] it was
really gross and it bugged the [__] out
of me so many times I was just like you
know what I'm cleaning your kitchen I'm
tired of this and she's like please
don't just leave it and I said no no
there's no room in your fridge anymore I
need to clean it cleaned it out cleaned
out the cupboards and [__] and uh
just a bad Stroke of Luck the very next
morning there was a rat infestation okay
and
became my fault again it was like
wait why
you you tell me okay uh there's never
been everyone knows rat's like a clean
kitchen yeah well what's funny is they
it they ended up I ended up tracing
tracing it back to her bedroom closet
there was a an earthquake go bag that
they had chewed through and made their
way into the kitchen but uh so again I'm
like all right you know what no problem
this really sucks my girlfriend is
[__] temporarily handicapped and uh
now she's got a rat infestation but I
was like pack your bag you're coming in
living with me like let's go without
even questioning it like let's go
took her back to my place and uh you
would think that a person in that
situation would be so endeared to to
their partner for like stepping up and
doing what they need to do she uh she
accused me of somehow engineering these
things
to you apartment trapped her to well to
uh to make her dependent on me
and I I remember sitting there going
I
I I like wanted to make fun of her and
be like yeah no I was in the gym going
fall [__] you got it ball [__] like ah
using my it's all going according to
play yeah and then summoning the rats
I'm Gonna Leave little bits of peanut
butter all over the [__] trail of it
to make and I it was one of those things
where yeah at the time I didn't think I
I also wasn't
um because I with with
this other relationship I like had
talked to my friends about it too much
and didn't I just felt like I don't want
to Poison the Well with anything anymore
I'm just gonna deal with my relationship
problems privately and so I didn't like
talk to anybody about it
and I'm like oh man
that was not a good that was not a good
thing that was a uh because yeah at the
time I just thought oh yeah no she's
upset but to be like
you are some kind of Mastermind who like
your reaction that feels good your
reaction was just like what the [__]
yeah yeah no definitely
um so yeah that was just yeah and uh you
did all that just so she would move in
with you yeah gotcha [__]
um
but yeah so it that that's that's
a thing that I've learned it's like okay
someone who you show up for but also can
like receive it yeah and not and not um
and not for some reason view you as like
a [__] opposing force in their in
their life for whatever reason you know
yeah